we immediately see the extra vram
compared to 8 GB cards pay off with the
b570 in Horizon forbidden West at 1080p
very high settings where the b570 is
Comfortably giving a 65 FPS average
whereas the 6600 is only hitting 43 but
not only that it's getting additional
spikes on its frame time graph uh
stutters as it goes over its vrm
capacity leading to a 77% Advantage for
the b570 in the 1% lows it's important
to note though that if we drop down to
the medium settings that the
differential between the two cards is
well very different because we're now
within the 8 GTE vram buffer when this
happens the b570 is now hitting 87 FPS
uh but the 6600 is now closing the Gap a
bit at 73 the b570 still has a very
noticeable lead by 19% and 14% in the 1%
lows but you see that less of a dramatic
advantage and that's because we're now
within that 8 GB vram buffer but that is
one of the advantages of the b570 with
that 10 GB now let's pause here for a
second though and talk about why am I
even comparing the RX 6600 with the b570
uh first of all I've already done an
Nvidia comparison against the RTX 3050
uh when doing my AMD comparison for the
b570 it was actually a little harder for
me to choose which graphics card to
compare against because uh the b570 is
meant to cost $220 that's the MSRP the
b580 has so far kind of above its MSRP
maybe Supply things we'll have to see
what happens but it's meant to cost $220
I have the azrock Challenger version
over here I got as a review sample now
with AMD though here's the issue uh if
I'm going current gen we have the RX
7600 But that's $250 meaning it's a
direct exact price competitor to the
b580 at least if we compare on MSRP for
the b580 hopefully it gets back there uh
so I don't think it makes sense to
compare the b570 directly against that
exactly so if I go down a bit we can go
to the uh
6600 uh and this is available as low as
190 it's generally priced around 200 and
there's a few models available in that
price range at at 190 200 200 210 and
then there's the 6600 XT version uh
which is currently going for around 240
but by that point you're basically at
the 250 Mark again b580 competition and
uh
so so I don't think that necessarily
again makes sense again there was also
the 6650 XT which for a while you could
get around the $220 to $240 range but
currently those lower price models don't
seem to be available any longer so
that's why I've gone with these 6600
here but it is important to note that
there is that price difference which
means the b570 if we're talking
percentage differentials we should also
talk about the price differential uh
where if we do 220 divided by 190 we can
see that the uh b570 costs an extra
16% so if you see a result like this
where it's 19% faster that means that it
is offering better value but only by a
little bit although when we see results
like we saw at the very high settings
where it's 51% faster that's so much
faster than the amount extra that you're
paying that it's definitely offering
better value than the 6600 so that's
just stuff to keep in mind when we're
looking at these results I'll have some
summary graphs at the end of the video
but for now let me pop into the corner
and go through all of the specific
benchmark results I've tested 1080P and
1440p uh so perhaps let's jump into some
1440p results at 1440p very high
settings uh no surprise that we're once
again seeing vram issues on the 8 GB
card leading to a 79% Advantage for the
b570 that being said the b570 is only
averaging 50 FPS here the 6600 is
totally unusable at 28 you might use the
b570 at these settings but again since
we are under 60 FPS now I find this to
be a less uh realistic test case than
the 1080p very high settings where I
thought those were very much the way you
might play the game on the b570 uh at
1440p dropping down to medium settings
might even be something that you'd want
to do on the b570 which brings it to a
32% lead over the RX 6600 still more
than making up for its price uh price
premium um so it is offering better
value here overall also on the vram
issue sometimes you don't have to go
with you know just default presets so if
you could have enabled perhaps the very
high texture settings on the b570 with
otherwise reduced settings to get a bit
a bit of better performance that's
another thing you can do with that
additional vram but for today's video
we're sticking uh mostly to Graphics
presets um jumping into a less demanding
game like balers Gate 3 uh both GP can
do just fine at the ultra settings at
1080P and here the b570 is only giving
us a 3% Advantage at 76 versus 74 so
it's a win and the 1% lows are win by 8%
but here is an example of it not making
up for its uh price difference right
cost 16% more isn't 16% faster at 1440p
ultra settings it does increase its
advantage to 8% in the averages and
actually to 23% in the 1% lows and it
has a bit of a smoother frame time graph
uh you can see on the uh AMD side of the
frame time graph there's these
intermittent spikes and I'm not seeing
that so much on the
b570 so that's a bit interesting uh
let's go ahead and move to Final Fantasy
16 even at the low settings neither GPU
can deliver 60 FPS at 1080p but the b570
gets a lot closer at 50 frames per
second which gives it a 25% advantage
over the RX 6600 which is hitting 40 FPS
uh if we go up to 1440p resolution you
not only need to be at low settings but
even enabling some upscaling uh to get
to near 60 FPS on the b570 but you're
still not there you're only hitting 50
here but the 6600 is only hitting 43 so
it gives us 16% Advantage for the
b570 uh quick note on upscaling results
pause here for a second uh notice I'm
saying FSR and xss 66% what the heck do
I mean by that uh well FSR and uh dlss
both call FSR and dlss quality the same
internal rendering resolution xcss used
to follow that naming scheme until its
1.3 version where it changed the naming
scheme where quality now refers to an
even lower rendering resolution and the
ultra quality XS setting is matching the
internal resolution that FSR and dlss
called the quality setting so you could
think of this as FSR Quality dlss
quality xss gets a different name which
is why I'm not calling them quality I'm
calling it 66% because it's that's the
per axis uh resolution uh scaling that
that they're using here it's downscaling
it by to 66% per axis anyway long story
short I've matched the internal
rendering resolution however that being
said I should also mention I think the
xcss upscaler looks better than the FSR
upscaler so that is a visual Advantage
even though they have the same internal
rendering resolution uh so uh that's
nice and I actually have seen xss
available in a ton of the games that
I've been testing um Call of Duty Black
Ops 6 I've tested at the basic preset
because I'm assuming you're going to be
playing a competitive online game trying
to chase High frame rates rather than
cranking up the visual settings at these
settings the RX 6600 actually gets a win
by 12% at 124 FPS versus
111 do keep in mind though that AMD
cards tend to perform really well in
this game Call of Duty Black Ops 6 uh is
uh again and Call of Duty games in
general seem to perform really well in
AMD gpus uh so uh this is a little bit
less representative what we'll see in
other games also if we move up to 1440p
resolution the b570 closes the Gap
showing that again at the higher
resolutions uh it tends to increase its
performance relative to the 6600 now
they're basically tied at 82 and 81 1%
lead for the 6600 in the averages uh
however % lead and the 1% lows for the
b570 in general I'd basically call this
a tie however again chasing High frame
rates in a competitive game I think a
lot of people would actually want to go
over over 80 FPS here so we're already
down at the basic preset so all that's
left is kicking on more upscaling and
both this does have xess and FSR if we
set them both to the same internal
rendering resolution we're now again
pretty much matching performance they're
both hitting 101 FPS average although
the b570 does have a very small lead in
the 1% l lows at 84 versus
81 uh let's go ahead and jump into
cyberpunk so cyberpunk 2077 at 1080p
ultra settings uh this is a pretty good
performance for the b570 we're seeing it
hit 83 FPS here versus 60 FPS on the RX
6600 that's a 38% Advantage for the b570
again way more than making up for the
16% price increase and a 29% lead in the
1% lows however what about Ray tracing
now gpus of this caliber are just not
going to be Ray tracing monsters and I
don't think it should be a major part of
your purchasing decision that being said
it does look like the b570 crushes the
RX 6600s Ray tracing in this game notice
I've only turned on RT Reflections
though I felt like the RT Ultra setting
RT overdrive settings that was too much
even the RT medium setting was too much
but if I I was able to enable uh RT
Reflections and still be pretty playable
on the b570 at a 51 FPS average I'd
still probably personally keep it off
and go with the much higher frame rate
that we had without it since we're below
60 FPS here the 6600 only hitting 31 FPS
though so it's a 65% lead for the b570
and a 74% advantage in the 1% lows um I
did try out uh upscaling which I don't
like doing at 1080p um I just don't
think there's a lot of pixels to work
with but look at the bottles in the back
right now it's really shimmery on the RX
way more stable on the uh uh b570 again
showing off that the xcss uh machine
learning based upscaler does have image
quality advantages over FSR so I would
say that here the b570 is not only
performing 61% better than the RX 6600
but its upscaler is producing a nicer
looking image um and we're now hitting
74 FPS on the b570 so frame rate wise
this is definitely playable that being
said I'm still not sure if Trading the
uh image uh quality for the better
Reflections is the trade-off I would
make personally in this case uh I might
still just play at Native 1080p Ultra on
the b570 uh without upscaling to get the
RT Reflections going anyway at 1440p
resolution I'm not going to try to push
upscaling since already at the ultra
settings without upscaling neither GPU
is breaking 60 FPS the b570 though is
very playable at 54 FPS oras the RX 6600
is only hitting 34 that gives a 59%
advantage to the b570 so it's really
looking like cyberpunk is a good showing
for the The Arc GPU here uh let's go
ahead and kick on upscaling So since
neither GPU was hitting 60fps I tried
kicking on the uh the upscaling again at
the 66% setting and here we see the uh
41% Advantage for the b570 again if you
look at things like the bottles in the
back behind the bar here you'll see way
more shimmering and lack of stability on
the FSR upscale compared to the XS so
good image quality Advantage there and
again 41% faster as well 65 versus
46 uh let's go ahead and move into ghost
of sushima at 1080p maximum settings
which is called very high in this game
both gpus uh do well uh at 60 FPS on the
6600 but 66 FPS on the b570 that's a 10%
Advantage however note that again it's
16% more money so this is a case where
the 6600 is showing better value at
least in this particular game that's at
1080p uh at 1440p though the b570
increases its V advantage to
38% at 51 versus 37 so if you're gaming
on a 1440p screen uh the b570 is again
showing that it's uh expands its lead at
the higher resolutions uh also nice to
have the additional vram here and the
arc b570 is showing allocation above 8
gab so it is possible that that's
helping out here at these settings uh if
we use upscaling uh on the very high
preset uh we're now seeing the b570 go
to 65 FPS and 51 FPS on the RX 6600
giving a 27% advantage to the
b570 and I would say xss I still think
looks a little better here especially
like a fizzle behind moving objects like
the bird um however I would do say think
that this is a this game looks pretty
good with FSR I think this one of the
better games for FSR image quality wise
but I do still think the XS image does
still have the advantage now God of War
Ragnarok at 1080p medium settings I had
to go down to medium settings to get the
gpus near 60 FPS in my test scene here
uh the b570 is hitting 57 FPS and the
6600 is hitting 59 which does mean the
6600 has a win here this have been
pretty few and far between although
again it does cost less uh it's winning
by 4% though so it's basically a tie all
of the 1% lows are a 9% Advantage both
gpus basically hanging out around 60fps
here though pretty similar experience if
you didn't run a frame rate counter at
1440p medium settings the b570 takes a
28% lead so again showing a pretty
significant Advantage at 1440p in a game
where it didn't have one at 1080p kind
of interesting 46 vers 36 so the thing
is 46 FPS is still maybe not you'd want
to play the game so if we kick on
upscaling on the medium preset the b570
is now hitting 57 FPS average so uh
again pretty playable here right around
60 FPS the 6600 goes up to 48 but that
means the b570 is winning by 19% and
again if you look at the upscaler things
in motion like this grass uh and as as
objects are discluded meaning uncovered
by the player character I think FSR is a
little more fizzling xss has less so I
think image quality and performance win
here for the B5 70 uh let's take a look
at a uh Unreal Engine 5 graphical
showcase like hellblade 2 sen was Saga
uh we have to go down to medium settings
to to get um decent performance here
which would be at 46 FPS interestingly
both gpus are exactly tied 46 average 42
one in the 1% lows um now in this game
because it's so slow paced and you do a
lot of just walking around looking at
things and solving puzzles I actually
think 46 FP s might be perfectly
playable I don't really think you need
60 FPS in this game especially if you
end up playing on a controller on a
variable refresh rate display that being
said if you do want to be closer to 60
FPS you would have to go down to low
settings Andor use upscaling which I try
to avoid at 1080p if possible uh so at
1080p low the b570 is hitting 54 the
6600 is hitting 56 so that does give it
the 6600 to 4% Advantage again I would
say that if you're not running a frame
rate counter these would be delivering a
virtually identical experience you're
not really going to tell be able to tell
which GPU you were
using uh if we jump up to 1440p low
settings b570 is hitting 41 FPS 6637 so
now the b570 has an advantage again at
1440p that it didn't have at 1080p it's
now winning by 11% in the averages and
16% in the 1% lows 41 FPS in this game
again maybe playable given how slow
paced this game is I'd probably want to
chase a bit higher settings we're
already at the low preset though so what
are you going to do use upscaling um
Unreal Engine 5 tends to respond
extremely well to upscaling from a
performance standpoint and the b570
jumps all the way to 68 FPS the 6600
jumps up to 60 though so they're both
giving you a 60 FPS experience but the
b570 is faster by 133% almost making up
for its 16% price increase but xcss once
again I do think is delivering better
image quality so despite performance
being uh somewhat similar I do think the
results look better on the arc GPU uh
here we're looking at Silent Hill 2
since this game had Ray tracing I did
test it and when I test ray tracing I
usually do it as an uh a setting above
the maximum so if you already at Epic
settings and then kick on Hardware
accelerated Ray tracing neither GPU can
break 30 FPS so while this is a 44%
Advantage for the b570 I would classify
both of these as unusable settings if
you try to use upscaling to increase
performance which again I don't love
doing 1080p but here we go um we do see
the b570 winning by 54% now and hitting
37 FPS game's pretty slow paced maybe
some people would choose to do this I
probably wouldn't personally however
look at his hair I think the F in FSR
the hair looks very pixelated in xss it
still looks somewhat pixelated but much
less so um similar things if you look at
the foliage and motion and things like
that so I do think this is another
example of xcss having better image
quality than FSR now at 1080p low
settings uh that's actually how far down
you have to go if you want to be around
60 FPS even the medium settings are
below 60 FPS on the b570 so at low
settings 1080p native resolution the
b570 is winning by 22% at 67 versus 55
uh and 27% advantage in the 1% lows 42
versus 33 both have some spikes in the
frame time graph but this is just one of
those Unreal Engine 5 games that's kind
of like that sometimes Unreal Engine 5
just doesn't have the most smooth frame
times if we move up to 1440p even at the
low settings we're not going to break 60
FPS but the b570 is very playable at 53
FPS so on a variable refresh rate
display in a slow paced game like this
that might be totally fine it's a 36%
advantage over the 39 FPS that we're
seeing on the RX 6600 and a 20% lead and
the 1% lows however if you do want to
get to 60 FPS uh you might need to try
out upscaling that gets the b570 up to
58 FPS uh which is a 26% advantage over
the 6600 which is only hitting 46 once
again if you look at the hair and stuff
like that I think you can still an image
quality Advantage for xss although it's
less pronounced than it was at 1080p uh
where upscaling is a lot harder to do
and that is my Benchmark results that I
had time to get you uh so how about we
summarize all of it let's take a look at
this chart so this chart is just
everything I tested both 1080P and 1440p
with the few Ray tracing results thrown
in there and this is not frame rates so
so these numbers you're seeing here is
not frames per second this is a
percentage differential between the gpus
so this is the b570 divided by the 6600
getting us its percentage advantage in
the games where the 6600 have had the
lead um I the negative uh numbers here
are representing Advantage for the 6600
the positive numbers are representing
Advantage for the b570 so what you can
see here is that uh this is the split so
all of these games here are Advantage
b570 we've got basically two ties and
then three wins for the 6600 although
they're much less significant winds
compared to what we're getting on the
b570 so is the b570 faster than the 6600
yes the exact difference varies wildly
and that's something that we see with
the Intel Arc gpus is just their their
performance just is less consistent game
to game but it's overall faster than the
6600 and if I do the geome mean of these
results it comes out to 24% faster on
average um although you can see that
some results are dramatically faster and
a lot of that's due especially in games
where the vram capacity uh became an
issue although that didn't happen in a
lot of games anyway uh if you prefer to
see this split game by game rather than
in order from you know greatest to least
win for the b570 it looks like this uh
so you can see it more like all the
different games group The all test
settings on the different games group
together so this is the same results but
organized differently um if you want to
uh just look at 1080p results this is
what we would see so if we just look at
1080p the b570 is 22% faster um so a
little bit less but again still it's
overall a win for the b570 and if we
look at the 1440p results although I'm
also including the upscaled results in
the same chart because I think that's a
very valid way to play at 1440p
especially on cards of this performance
level I think it's very likely you would
be using some upscaling uh here we see
that there's that the worst result for
the b570 was a tie and that um most
results uh were a win and some of them
significantly so the geomine here is 26%
faster so it is a bit better at 1440p
relative to 1080p when compared with the
6600 and that's not surprising now I
didn't set out toest rate tracing I just
tested some games and if the games had
rate tracing I enabled it so the the
only two games I tested had rate tracing
and I tested it with upscaling and
without and only at 1080p cuz 1440p rate
tracing on these cards I I just think is
asking too much uh it is clear though
that the b570 was massively faster in
these cases by
56% um on on average if we do the geom
mean so is the b570 better at R tracing
yes were was the rate tracing
performance good enough that I think
it's a major selling point no but if
you're going to be enabling any rate
tracing and some games don't allow you
to turn it off these days the extra vram
plus the extra R tracing performance is
certainly something to maybe uh mention
now do keep in mind once again though
the price difference you can get the
6600 for for as low as 190 so let's do a
little bit of a value calculation here
at the end so if the uh b570 is about
16%
faster um uh sorry not faster 16% % more
expensive uh but it's on average about
24% faster we could do a calculation
like this uh
1.24 uh that's how much faster it is as
a expressed as a multiplication amount
right it's 1.24 times faster but it's
also about 1.16 times uh more expensive
so this is your performance Rao divided
by your price ratio uh which means it's
offering about 7% better value however
that additional vram uh also is nice the
better upscaler also is nice so there's
all of that so this is looking pretty
good compared against the RX 6600 which
has been my go-to recommendation around
uh $200 the last thing I should uh
should mention to maybe rain on the
parade or at least maybe not rain on the
parade but you should consider this if
you're deciding to buy buy the b570
couple of things number one Intel Arc
gpus require resizable bar support if
you are on a very old old motherboard
CPU platform you need to check that
resizable bar is uh supported on your
motherboard you might need to download a
bios update in order to enable it and um
make sure that that's available for you
do not buy an Intel Arc GPU if you do
not have resizable bar support make sure
you check that first if you're on new
newer platforms uh like you're buying a
whole new pc latest generation Parts
shouldn't be an issue older parts that's
something you're going to want to check
that brings up one more thing to
consider if buying older Parts uh in uh
testing done by Hardware unboxed and
Hardware Canucks is that how you
pronounce it I people criticized my last
pronunciation of it I'm not a Canadian
whatever anyway um it's been shown that
Arc gpus become CPU bottlenecked at
lower frame rates than AMD and Nvidia
gpus meaning that while I'm benchmarking
on a super high-end CPU here 9800 x3d to
isolate GPU performance is the variable
if you're on a weaker CPU it's you could
potentially uh become CPU bottleneck in
situations where you wouldn't if you
went with like the RX 6600 for example
that being said it's generally a lot
faster and I think you are more likely
to be GPU bottleneck than CPU bottleneck
unless you're on an extremely weak old
CPU so I still think that the this makes
sense so if you have resizable bar
support uh and are at least on a
reasonable full CPU uh platform I still
think the the extra 2 GB of vram and a
lot more performance uh does mean I'd
rather have the b570 than the 6600 does
cost a little bit more uh but there's
that that's kind of my conclusion of the
video hopefully you guys enjoyed it I've
also tested it up uh against the RTX
3050 which was nvidia's closest price
competitor um and it's it's a bit of a
blood bath cuz the 6600 is already
faster than the 3050 so there's that but
you take a look at that video for the
details and I hope all of you have an
excellent day